.
UNRELIABLE CAN MEAN A LOT OF
THINGS THAT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING HE REPORTED WAS WRONG.
>> Jesse: WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO CUT YOU OFF BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
NOW SPEAKING IN BALI, INDONESIA.
ON THE HEELS OF THIS ALLEGING
RUSSIAN MISSILE STRIKE INSIDE
POLAND THEY KILLED TWO POLISH
CITIZENS.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT,
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW SO
FAR ABOUT THE EXPLOSION IN
POLAND?
>> THANKS, GUYS.
[REPORTERS SPEAKING]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHO ACTUALLY
CALLED THE LID BEFORE DINNER AND
FINALLY WOKE UP AND FOUND OUT
RUSSIAN MISSILES HAD REPORTEDLY
STRUCK INSIDE A NATO ALLY'S
TERRITORY, KILLING TWO POLISH
CITIZENS, WAS ASKED ABOUT THAT
AND HE SAID NO.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT
OR HE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
ALL THE WORLD HEARD WAS NO.
THAT'S STRIKING BECAUSE USUALLY
IN TIMES LIKE THIS, AFTER HE'S
TOLD PRIVATE GROUPS DURING
FUND-RAISERS THAT WE COULD BE ON
THE PRECIPICE OF NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON AND HOW HE IS
REPORTEDLY ASSURED NATO ALLIES
THAT ANY STRIKE INSIDE NATO
TERRITORY WOULD BE